rebecca mark how's my girl demure today
i feel a lot more demure i feel a lot
more you looked at me yeah i looked in
here don't i yeah cecil b demille and
all that [ __ ] you're always so stylish
you take stuff out of the wherever you
find it trash it's all trash today it
was all trash but you turn it into the
most stylish interesting stuff yeah
style 360 nikki hilton
pull that pull that down okay
there you are yeah
yeah i like that i honestly really don't
like it it's just giving me something to
do with my day so you were in the you
went to the hospital yesterday yeah i
went for exhaustion and i was like you
were out of it yesterday i was out of it
yesterday kind of no this guy ran after
me so i was like
yeah it seems like they gave you a
sedative
yeah they did yeah you're a little bit
slower yeah i'm slower today and i uh i
mean instead of in the morning too
[ __ ]
i'll be all right more than anybody i
interview i just want to scoop you up
and lock you into a room for about two
months i would do that i swear you would
i would really you'd probably clean out
my house though i i'd clean the house i
don't mean clean the house you'd clean
up the
people always think i'm that kind of
person no no no i don't i actually don't
think you're that kind of person yeah i
know i i would actually trust you but
i'm actually very respectful of people's
faces
i might just do that one day
more
one of these is not like the other
i'd love it if you did mark really yeah
even though i hate the palisades i
totally come check your place out
are you dating anyone i'm not
good neither am i what are you doing
what are you what are you implying what
am i implying i'm playing nothing you're
not my kind of girl you're not my kind
of guy
no but i don't mean i wouldn't have
disappeared you know you have a great
body but your face you know like it's
your demeanor
like you come across kind of like a like
not like a serial killer but you know
when you've just killed someone yes and
you and you no i don't no but okay well
you know when you're just killing
someone and you're with a group of
people
and there's always that one guy that's
like oh my god dude we're all gonna go
to jail [ __ ] up you know
you give me that attitude sometimes i
give you that energy yeah well you're
out of your mind half the time you come
by here yeah that's right that's that's
probably why
but i'm fascinated by you i think you're
amazing i think you're amazing i would
love to see you thrive realize some of
your potential i'd love to i still don't
know what my potential is i mean i'm
little eddie b who over here like
roxy heart ever saw the end of that
movie [ __ ]
uh chicago so if i trapped you in my
place or someplace and you never got
access to meth and all the other drugs
you play around with molly and stuff
how would you function i'd function i
wouldn't say about without math but i'd
function for sure would you lose your
mind no i wouldn't i'd have something to
do wouldn't i
i'm not sure if you'd had something to
do i don't have anything to do right now
honestly so you know it's kind of a
stalemate right now is that is that the
problem you need an anti-drug you need
something no it's not the drug it's the
drug gives me a motivation to do
something no but i'm saying if you
weren't doing a drug you would need
something to replace it yes of course
like food probably get fat or whatever
you did you did put on weight that one
time when you yeah i did put on weight
that one time let's not discuss it
be very bad some people say it's funny
some people said you look good and i
yeah right me too
i can't say anything about waiting when
people compliment those videos i'm like
no i always come in here remember that
one time i came in here there'll be
species on me like
no i'm always here when i'm at my most
disheveled
yes usually i'd like to get you at your
most sober bit yeah i know i'm coming
here sober most of the time yeah
actually all the time but sometimes
you're out of your mind yeah
i'm out of my mind but i'm just sober no
i come here sober there was one time i
saw you on spring street i gave you
20 or 40 i think i gave you 40 bucks oh
yeah and you left it on the sidewalk and
walked away yeah
i'm like i remember you i can't really
help anybody that can't even hold on to
twenty bucks no i wasn't no that was
that was a kid thing with me and i was
kid though i was really bad with money
people give me money and i always drop
it yeah yeah that was one weird thing
you don't have pockets usually i don't
have power you don't have pockets right
now i have a bag today though
oh you have a purse yeah i was a purse
yeah i fished something out of the trash
i hate it but i needed her first it's
the ugliest thing i've ever seen in my
life so i'm going to take advantage of
this sober moment yeah that i have with
you
do you have a family that we could
contact no i don't come on i really
don't
why not because you told me the last a
few few talks ago that you started
crying when you started talking with
your mom yeah but my mom or the moms
that like whoever the stylist that i'm
thinking of yeah but i don't have her
contact information
we met once her handler set it up
you know through the adoption agency or
whatever you were adopted
that's a hoarse croc of [ __ ] compared to
what it actually is but yeah i was taken
and away and made to live with other
people who weren't really in my family
because my mother was deemed in fit
so i was like i said i was raised very
nicely by some very wealthy people who
treated me like garbage
so they they would not be the ones that
contacted if i wanted to no no they
wouldn't your biological mom is not
he's not interested in no she is
interested i just don't know how to
reach her
i generally i don't have her number
i try to get her on instagram ones
anyway
and she's a famous
person she's a stylist maybe
maybe she's rachel's own maybe she's
someone who's like rachel though
you're very mysterious i know but i
don't mean to be
like i'm not actually putting on a front
of like a thumb fatale you know what i
mean i genuinely wish that i could sit
here and outpour to you the details of
my family it's just like the vanderbilts
you know what i mean like
you know
how they had a really [ __ ] up kind of
thing going on
a lot of princesses
what would you do if you got your life
together you got clean i'd model you
would model i'd model yeah
i just needed shave
i've got castings and everything so
here's what i could see happening let's
let's say you
somehow miraculously we got
you clean
which i would love and i'm very open for
i don't know you think i'm as open for
it as i am like i go with you right now
but you always seem so busy yeah i am
busy but yeah but this is an opportunity
that i might just have to
take advantage of how you think about it
um
i i can imagine especially if we did
some talks and and showed my audience
how
together you've become
over time
this isn't going to happen in a week no
obviously but
over time we could maybe
show how much potential you have
and maybe someone would offer you a
position somewhere and that would be
that was something i'd be very grateful
for
like i read through the comments and
honestly a lot of it was the same old
kind of pity which i don't mind like i'm
not gonna destruct on an audience it's
like oh i hope she's okay oh i hope
she's this and like
yeah but it's more proactive to be like
hey how about i help you with lack of
clothes or whatever those are those
concerts you're like can i leave
thousands of clothes and i'm like i'd
love to
also do you have a blazer
i don't i need a blaster to go with that
because i want to put my blue dress back
i'm just gonna need a blazer
well this is interesting maybe maybe
we'll figure something out maybe we will
i mean
you think you're
capable of staying foot and not running
off yeah i'm capable of staying foot not
running off
i know where you are it's just i never
know how to reach you because i don't
have a phone and i don't know your hours
like i'll come by here sometimes like
when i'm out here on really dark days
and your office will be closed yeah i'm
not here every day yeah i mean
weekends yeah usually did weekdays
all right let's see if we can work out
all right this might be an opportunity
that i haven't had in a while with you i
would love that i'd appreciate that
this is this is a real surprise because
you were getting worse and worse lately
worse and worse i just wonder what they
gave you last night at the hospital oh
my god thorazine
so straight up playing they're still in
your shoes yeah no i can't i can't be
injecting you with thorazine everything
no but it's just like i just woke up
from enough you know what i mean so i'm
kind of like earth
more irritated
i still did drugs today though like
i know how to consume or control myself
on drugs just know today yeah it's like
i'm on heroin or something right
there's a place called the dream center
that would be great for somebody like
you is that lgbtq
what's that i can go to the lgbt center
in kantai in west hollywood i just never
know how to get there well i can take
you
i'd love it if you told me if you told
me one day i had to clap how about right
now okay all right done done we're gonna
do it right now okay
thanks rebecca thanks mark
are you rebecca i'm feeling fabulous
feeling [ __ ] today you feeling what
feeling
i say i gave you money for a room last
night you're sleeping on the sidewalk
yeah i know i couldn't afford it it was
250 mark you lied 250 the continental's
probably about 60 bucks right now i
don't have id mark oh that game's about
id
you gotta let me in mark
i don't need a house i need a phone can
you get me a phone
buy me a phone mark you want to sell it
for drugs i won't just stop for drugs i
swear on myself i thought you wanted to
go to the
lbqty place [ __ ] that i need a phone
hey gorgeous hey beautiful how are you
terrible mark
mark i should have gotten a hotel room
like you said i gave you money for it i
know but i went to west hollywood and i
partied
i went to the abbey and i got drinks
i snuck in yeah
the bouncer wasn't looking and i ran in
and i bought people drinks
i bought two boys two drinks i love that
you're honest with me no i didn't [ __ ]
them really
i just wanted a power move on a story
i went to the abbey
so last night you were on on board for
going to the lbqty
no i don't do charity mark
i do empathy maybe but not charity sorry
no offense you know some people need a
kick in life you're you're heavily you
were heavily sedated yesterday i am
heavily sedated yesterday
what am i gonna do with you
take me in get me a phone and a room and
lock the doors shut what are you going
to call if you had a phone i won't call
anyone you guys should listen to music
i'm going to listen to music and watch
videos mainly i want to watch videos
mark
on watch videos with audio dude i broke
into a building and there were because
there were computers and literally the
audio was [ __ ] turned off you needed
headphones so i just watched endless
loops of the olsen twins [ __ ] on no
audio because i can't find a zero show
on the internet now there's something i
must complain about there are no
episodes of the rachel zoe project on
the internet and there are no
zero designed by american ashley olsen
fashion shows on the internet and that
is something that i despise anyway
continuing on the situation in iraq is
terrible mark
i mean really bangladesh you know what i
mean
you're in love with rachel zoe i'm gonna
i'm really in love with rachel though i
really am that's my mommy right there
that's
no because really on the internet the
kids do it with lord lord you know the
14 year old singer they're like mother
that's mava to me is rachel's though
that's my fat god you stole my singers
i love her
i love you rachel's though moving on
we're talking about me mark please yes
i'm talking about you
let's just talk more about me you know
what i mean unless about the situation
in iraq or the bangladeshi no one's more
interesting than rebecca to me what
about bangladesh mark
rebecca moving on
rebecca smoking
taboo
fetish my favorite fashion editor is by
bed dijon and my favorite magazine is
numero and my favorite movie which
you've never asked me before is funny
games us
interesting let's hear more about about
you okay what do you want to know what
music you like um
uh
witch house
and techno
this week
now
when's your birthday 4th of august 1997.
i swear to god you've been alone before
a man i'm going to call mr demille i
don't want to say his name yeah you
don't give her names yeah i know he's
known um i dated him for a while i did
it him when i was 16 and he was quite a
bit older and people found out in my
family and were really pissed off at me
um and i'm still in love with him to
this day but we can't be together he's
really um he's well known he's italian
he's italian and i'm russian
yeah no really i'm russian my
grandmother's russian
i don't speak a word of it but you know
where'd you meet
um at a disco in paris um i grew up in
paris i told you yeah between paris i
met him actually at the club san sio
and like we made out at the club
silencio it was crazy the club center
was a club that david lynch opened
anyway
cheers thanks a lot
what's your favorite time of year of
your life
fall winter ah
i'm sorry fall winter isn't no but
favorite favorite year favorite thing
this year this year for sure really yeah
no really you're living on the street
like a rat i'm living like a rock dude
i'm in liberty look at me i'm wearing
chanel
trust me i would know i would think
being in paris and no paris look paris
was complicated because i grew up as a
boy growing up in paris as a boy is
disgusting
you have to be really like a [ __ ] you
know what i mean you'll be like a [ __ ]
and my dad molested me plus all the time
but you have to be really a [ __ ] and
you have to like but you also you were
molested too oh yeah i wasn't laughing
everybody you can't even get in this
door if you haven't been molested yeah
you gotta get in the door you haven't
been left that's how they got you
you know what i mean but i was raised um
muslim not catholic so it's a little
more taboo so there were rituals and
weird things that i had to do with other
men you know what i mean and videos and
stuff like i had to do really weird
things mark on video this is where in
paris mark
when you were old when i was like
three years old martin
are you just making up a story no i'm
telling you the truth but like let's not
talk about it you know what i mean it's
not
downgrade the scenario but yeah no no
no no no that's for real i swear to god
okay no but you tell me a lot of crazy
stuff yeah i know but everything i tell
you is true f wow
no i swear i really rachel zoe's your
mom which is those not my mom i'm sure i
wish i had you told me she was just
she's my mom as in well she's not mama
my mother is mama
i don't want to say my so you were
adopted yes i was adopted what happened
to your biological parents
we don't talk about them either
there's so many things we don't talk
about because they were artists mark
because my mother gave me up for
adoption she threw me in a dumpster okay
and i was adopted because the mother
couldn't have kids
okay
so and then i was molested for it and
then i later found out that he picked
her because she couldn't have kids
she was his second wife
she was like a trophy wife she was kind
of like a jockey oh
you know what i mean jackie owen male
and monroe you know i mean like imagine
if he married maryland first okay and
then went on to jockey can you imagine
what the world would be like
though
i love jackie osc and my stepmother
reminds me a lot of jacqueline
jacqueline bouvier kennedy onassis she
had mannerisms and she had plays and
it's one thing i lack you know what i
mean i like
i don't arch my back you're supposed to
arch your box well you're also living
yeah i know about street but look no no
but look like audrey hepburn or grace
kelly you know what i mean like lana
turner
like my favorite movie about hollywood
is mel hall and drive have you ever seen
mulholland drive i've seen parts of it
yeah exactly exactly so like um whatever
her name was lara flynn boyle or
rita you know what i mean like she's not
like the ingenue you know what i mean
like the whole persona aspect um
but she has a certain way
and she's just that way you know and i
don't have that i'm a rat not a cat
some people are cats
i'm a rat i go you're a rat
cat
cat
cat you're so interesting i'd rather be
doing this than having breakfast at
tiffany's it's a line you got into
breakfast you know they have breakfast
ceremonies now
really they do brunch you can do brunch
tiffany's for 100
yeah no really it's [ __ ] disgusting
so you hang out in west hollywood
sometimes yeah sometimes yeah i like it
there there's music there's bars yeah i
love it there but you come back to skid
row to sleep yeah no to get close
the clothes on the drugs are in skid row
the parties are in west hollywood i
can't afford the drugs in west hollywood
and i don't do coke but it doesn't
doesn't
don't a lot of the gay community in west
hollywood do uh crystal met
um that's none of my business because
the gay community does not support me
mark i was at an event last night
outside of the red line and this is the
truth
and a woman threatened to call the
police on me because i was standing
outside trying to bum a smoke
i'm like and they were supporting
a charity called something cute
that supports
homeless transgendered youth
she called the police on you she called
the police on me i didn't get arrested
of course i ran away i'm not [ __ ]
mark i've never been i'm interested i
got arrested once for a month pipe
really
not here in florida of all places
i love florida florida that's where the
gay community is at fort lauderdale or
um what was what's that island called
not not fire island um
um key west now florida miami miss
now that's where the gay community is i
don't know what the lgbtq community is
lesbians don't chill with gays okay
lesbians are bookish or they're bulldigs
or they're valkyries or they're more pc
i don't get this homogeny of people
i don't believe in the rainbow that's
why i believe in people as people i
don't care who you're [ __ ] if you're
[ __ ] them you're [ __ ] them you
want to get married you're married
otherwise can you please do your job
i wish more people would do their job so
we always complain about the fact that i
don't have a job
so i guess my job is to be this homeless
vagabond street urchin and it works no
but i'm very polite see but atm's always
like excuse me good morning can you
spend some money and then they go like
no i'll be like oh but nice blouse ooh
chicos
you know you are an amazing street
urchin i'm a really great street you can
see i'm all clean well-ish
i came in here smelling like [ __ ] once
and we still shot and it still got a ton
of views and that was the time that i
was called and i quote the worst jlo
impersonator in reno
i'll hold on to that comment that's the
only one i share so the only one i read
all the comments i'm like oh my god no
please no so you actually read the
comments on your videos oh yeah read the
comments yeah yeah i know i read the
comment section yeah oh my god it's so
cringy i love it all these people really
love me they really love me more because
i love you i love you
i love you mark you're like my best
friend i wish we could spend more time
together but you're always working i
work a lot you work a lot everybody
complains that i work too much well
you work pro bono you're uh you're a
non-profit
your meals on wheels
i'm a money losing operation but your
money is enough that might change soon
that might change soon no i can tell
you're gonna yeah come into a lot of
money see i used to read crystal ball
and i used to read tara i'm a real witch
by the way
yeah uh when i first yeah no no i'm a
witch yeah we never discussed that
aspect of things when i first came to la
i actually read tarot on the streets in
venice
that was my first gig here i was yeah
17. yeah i would love to go to go to go
to paris or venice with you no well i
mean venice alley i've been in first and
i've been eventually venice sucks us
venice sucks ass then it sucks us okay
it's like as i'd shot you seen asha
paris is awesome it's my favorite city
in the world and i love it
yes the left bank not the right bank
you'd be so much fun to go to paris with
oh yeah of course i would
you would have no idea
on an expense account of course no
but you can do flea markets in paris i
got a christian george dress for ten
dollars a christian drawer or a dress by
john galliano for ten dollars when when
were you living a straight life without
drugs without being on the street oh god
new york
no
growing up like being uh because i told
you that my step-father was a diplomat
so growing up in like addis ababa or
like i don't want to talk about it
mark i've signed pieces of paper i've
signed ndas so i don't talk about iron
man
i saw i literally signed an nda i got a
plane ticket really
what was it what was the worst time of
your life first period of your life my
childhood
like early childhood yeah my early
childhood
yeah once i turned eight i figured i
found cigarettes you know once i figured
the cigarette thought it was good
once i figured a freaking cigarette
outside of mine cigarettes saved my life
cigarettes and rachel's though
and the olsen twins yeah
oh i love them
i'm very fascinated by them i'm very
fascinated about how they they're
they're a modern american dynasty really
they're their own powerhouse but there's
no man involved you know what i mean
it's direct it's feminist it's opaque
but they're women
women don't need men anymore men are
becoming obsolete no men are not
becoming obsolete i think women need men
more than ever
what is that kovid
mark
what does men have to do as in covida as
in living nobody like you know what what
do men provide uh sperm no other than
that they that that's easily okay no no
no no no no
protection
dick
man builds skyscraper
and i leave it there
mark the reason people mistreat me in
life is because i'm a man and not
because i'm a woman mark
it's about my dick and my beard it's
about my balls balls chaff mark [ __ ]
don't
okay and i'm a feminist and i'm i'm not
a feminist you know what i'm not a
feminist
i believe in the equality of the sexes
at the end of the day
armpit hair
[ __ ]
i think you're so interested i know
right
i'm the martial [ __ ] brady of the
upper east side don't you know
do you feel like do you feel like nobody
understands you no i don't give a [ __ ]
don't understand why would you want to
understand me i'm very no but don't
don't you just love it when somebody
gets you no what i love is when people
hate on me i love when people hate them
people hate that i dress nicely for
instance people hate that i'm skinny see
a lot of women don't give me food
because i'm skinny like i literally beg
people's leftovers off them i do it it's
my primary source of food because to eat
nicely well aside from these 10 sushi
rolls that appear nearly out of nowhere
but um to eat nicely i have to beg like
erwan um whole foods
i could go to kroger
maybe
you know i could go to stock market
where do you go to eat typically uh a
little tokyo
leftover sushi leftover ramen i hate
ramen by the way
uh slurpee bowls it's like you ever seen
that movie old boy when he gets the
[ __ ] squid on his face yeah
yeah shh
we can keep that on the dl
it's disgusting i like rice balls i like
rice i like sushi i grew up eating a lot
of rice
i grew up partly in africa i don't want
to talk about it
but yeah anyway back to you mari i like
it when you're in this mood this is my
favorite rebecca mood i know right this
is my favorite i i see a lot of
rebecca's this is my favorite naughty
like snob
you're just so much fun let's not you
know
i'm so much fun you really are
we'll see our
are you like this when you're
not clean no
no i'm not what are you i do drugs mark
i do drugs i do drugs yeah i know but i
smoke cigarettes i do drugs models do
drugs
what are you what are you afraid of
[Music]
what am i afraid of
[Music]
heights
okay nobody pain what do you want pain
i'm afraid of pain
physical pain not emotional pain like
what if i getting beaten up on the
street
oh i don't feel pain from that no i'm
afraid of physical pain mark
i'm afraid of being um you know when
when uh when the anesthetic in an
operation doesn't work and you can feel
the operation you can feel the pain i'm
afraid of physical pain
like you play around with all these
drugs what have you somehow
unknowingly got fentanyl oh oh no i have
dude i once literally got battery acid
and and and my pookie blew up
my pookie blew up mark
my fookie blew up i passed out literally
i thought i died i woke up i was like oh
i'm so scared bro i love it here we go
have you odd before yes of course
iodine all the time
it makes you impervious dude it's like
it's like sugar just a spoonful of sugar
makes the medicine go around in the most
delightful
way
anyway moving on left with star kid life
was star i could have been a child star
you know i decided not to
my mom she wanted me an um of all things
opera
so i did opera lessons as a child yes it
was disgusting to do a male alto
like because i had yeah yeah yeah no
it's disgusting do you know there are
children in the opera people don't know
this
yeah it was the most awful thing and had
the most awful instructor he was so
strict what drugs did you do last night
i did a bamboo molly at the abbey
i did like a whole bag of molly at the
abbey i stole the baggie
i just little baggy and did the whole
thing in the toilet with some other
chick
yeah
how'd you get to west hollywood the boss
the 16 boss it runs from skid row
he's the most beautiful person with
he's more beautiful than the old saint
twins who have a boutique in western
hollywood called the row by the way that
you should visit the row on melrose
the row.com zero
persuasion
new fragrance
you have any regrets in your life
no
not one i imagine that was the answer no
really yeah not a single regret
how about that i would have been
surprised if you said yes yeah i know so
would i really then i know it would have
been with us by the devil himself mr
demille
then
that's all folks
all right rebecca so nice talking with
you again so nice talking with you
i'm gonna set you up with a phone so you
can listen to some music yes that's all
i want is a phone
i'll give you money for a room again but
not gonna give me twenty dollars on a
phone
dollars on phones 20 phone real good
done done
great seeing you great seeing you
[Music]
ah
rebecca
[Music]
you